[Music]
it's a thursday p-f-t-o-t and i am not
flying solo today chris sims is back we
had some fun during the program and
we're gonna have some more fun here now
because we don't have anybody telling us
when to shut up we can talk as long as
we want to talk and we can talk about
things we talked about during the show
we could talk about things we didn't
talk about during the show and one thing
we didn't talk about for the first time
probably in a long time is antonio brown
so let's start there
in part because and it's not nothing to
do with a helmet this is hard knocks
viewership in pittsburgh hbo released
the numbers yesterday and i was stunned
by the fact that in pittsburgh the
ratings more than tripled the national
average those steelers fans
love to see a train wreck involving a
guy that they now hate and they just
can't get enough of the fact that
antonio brown and the raiders are having
a hard time getting properly acquainted
given that antonio brown's got the
frostbite on the feed and the helmet
issue and the raiders are exasperated
mike mayok called him out and
uh and and to make it even better chris
we tweeted our story a link to our story
with the information about the
pittsburgh ratings tripling the national
average antonio brown retweeted it with
the message my ex still thinks about me
i think he still thinks about his ex his
ex definitely still thinks about him and
it is funny to see that just because
antonio brown has gone from pittsburgh
he is far from forgotten there and he is
far from forgetting them yeah well he he
burned one of the greatest football
cities and greatest football
organizations we've ever seen here in
america
and they're that fan base is awesome
they're arguably one of the best out
there too
and that yeah they want to tune in one
like you said because they they don't
like him right now uh or hate them all
together two they're gonna get the first
time inside look about all the things
they've heard about the last few years
but have never really been able to see
or figure out what the guy is really
like behind the scenes so i understand
that and of course maybe i hope the
pittsburgh fans have a little more
sympathy for mike tomlin that's what i
want to argue there more than anything i
mean mike thoman isn't the gm john
gruden is the gm and the head coach and
he brought antonio brown there and i
don't remember any four-month period or
five-month period why antonio brown was
in pittsburgh that had more drama and
issues than we've seen so far with
antonio brown and
i'd like some of the pittsburgh fans to
to recognize that and maybe apologize to
mike tomlin that way no i won't i won't
because mike tomlin created antonio
brown he created a b he allowed this guy
who was a sixth round pick out of
central michigan to become the diva that
he is it's on the coach to keep the guy
from turning into someone who comes and
goes as he pleases who pays attention to
his phone during meetings who has his
own house that he rents during training
camp when everyone else is living in a
dorm at st vincent's college
that he rents off site the coach allowed
him to become a b and now look should
the raiders have wanted him given all
this stuff well he's still a hell of a
player but mike tomlin is the one that
enabled this if he had nipped it in the
bud in 2011 2012 when antonio brown was
blossoming into one of the best
receivers in the nfl
all this stuff could have been avoided
well i i yes to a degree okay i'll agree
with some of that sentiment right but
that's easier said than done and
especially hey when the rest of the
organization backs a guy like antonio
brown financially i mean we've heard
guys like ryan clark right on espn he
was telling people back then don't pay
him he's going to act a fool once he
gets paid he's going to have the power
and leverage in his corner and he's
going to use it against everybody and
that's what happened too so i can't put
all of that on mike tomlin i understand
what you're saying it's definitely valid
but i just can't put it all on him um
but but either way i understand the
pittsburgh steelers fans tuning in to
watch it i mean i'm tuned in to watch it
it's been pretty damn good so far
all of these coaches get seduced by the
talent that's the bottom line yes if the
talent comes with baggage if there's
enough talent you'll deal with the other
stuff just like your dad's new york
giants did and bill parcells did and
bill belichick did sure lawrence taylor
that's right belichick makes exceptions
for no one but if you're lawrence taylor
he'll make an exception for you because
you get seduced by what the guy can do
when it's time to get on the football
field and by all appearances whatever
he's wearing on his head whatever's
going on with his feet antonio brown can
still get it done now in pittsburgh with
antonio brown gone and chris yesterday
we did a draft of the achilles heels
that can affect the various teams and
and i said the number two receiver in
pittsburgh could be an achilles heel
because number one we don't know who the
hell it's gonna be and number two there
may be more pressure on that guy than
there was on juju smith schuster last
year because we don't know whether or
not juju smith schuster can blossom into
the number one receiver that antonio
brown was and smith shuster says he is
working on catching balls down the field
the free balls they send down the field
i got to make those plays that's what i
focused on a lot catching the ball over
the shoulder and being able to be a
threat on the outside well if that's
something you're working on
that doesn't give me a whole lot of
confidence you're gonna be able to do it
you're working on it that's good but you
shouldn't have to work on it it already
should be part of your game and to just
take juju smith schuster and plug him
from number two to number one and put
two guys on him all the time and expect
him to do the things that antonio brown
did i don't know that that's as easy as
we think it's going to be no disrespect
to juju's skills and we've seen number
twos try to become number ones in the
past alvin harper it doesn't always work
and and
you know we're just assuming
you slide him into the top spot and
everything's gonna be fine these quotes
from juju smith schuster at least tell
us chris
we need to watch we need to wait well it
is the area of his game that i would go
it's probably the least impressive right
he's big he's strong he can break
tackles you see a lot of great catches
over the middle but the one thing i
don't think he does to defenses
necessarily is scare them with a deep
threat especially when he's on the
outside he doesn't have that type of
speed so i think he's trying to say yeah
he's working on that he realizes he's
going to be more of that
oh it's man-to-man big ben's just going
to throw it up to me now instead of
antonio brown and he wants to get better
at you know those balls that yes i am i
am tightly covered but you know big ben
puts a ball out here and i adjust the
proper way or puts it behind my back and
i can go get it that way so i understand
that aspect he's just trying to let you
know he's working on that as some area
that he thinks he needed to be better
but i think that is the biggest question
mike about juju smith schuster is can he
scare people with the nine route the go
route can he back them off consistently
enough to where then it opens up
everything else underneath because guys
are fearful he'll he'll catch a bomb
over their head from big ben
and and i just want again juju smith
schuster is a young guy and i love him
he's a great player i love his passion
for the game i don't know that i would
be sharing publicly anything that would
suggest i don't have utmost confidence
in my ability to do it that i'm working
on i just don't know that i want the
world to know that right now i don't
know how do you feel about that aspect
yeah i i i understand you but you're
saying i think you're right i probably
would not have said that either that
would probably be one i would just have
you know kept under wraps not even
brought attention to it or anything like
that because two hey you can't just
guarantee that every team's amazing at
scouting and gonna put everything
together right this might open some eyes
up to where some teams go you know wait
that is right i mean now that i look at
them he doesn't win a lot on the outside
and just blow by people and it might
change the approach of a coaching staff
or corners
what's going to happen in 17 days the
steelers go to new england stefan
gilmour see exactly what
juju smith schuster has said so what are
they going to do they're going to take
away his ability to run the routes that
he is comfortable running and they're
going to force him to do the things that
he's working on because they know he's
got less confidence in that he'd prefer
not to do that they're going to force
him to prove that he can and that may be
one of the ways that you slow down a
juju schmidt schuster in week one of his
experiment as the number one receiver in
pittsburgh uh yes definitely and i would
hope pittsburgh would know enough to go
hey this is not exactly the a plus part
of his game
and move him around let him work the
middle of the field let him catch
shallow crossers and you know
deep crossers across the middle in cuts
like that that's really where he is
awesome but still i think there's enough
talent there ultimately to scare people
away on that go route to where it'll be
effective enough to where it helps out
the rest of the game the rest of the his
game and the offense in general
all right we spend so much time talking
about the guys who aren't playing in the
preseason specifically the quarterbacks
it is a little refreshing even though
the preseason is meaningless to hear
from a guy like one of our favorites
texans quarterback desean watson when
asked how much he would like to play on
saturday against the cowboys in week
three of the preseason he said the whole
game really if i had to i just love to
play football anytime i get to play
especially in the nfl the best athletes
in the world an opportunity to get on
the field on a national stage is a
blessing a great opportunity for anybody
now maybe it's just because he's only in
his third year and maybe 10 years from
now he's going to be like aaron rodgers
and say i don't have anything to do
right with pre-season football i just
like to hear that i like to feel that
from a guy who just loves the sport and
he's not jaded yet and he he has that
that passion for it and he you know you
put the uniform on you put the ball in
your hands football is football
regardless of what the stakes are so i
kind of like it i don't think it's the
smartest sentiment and you don't want to
see the guy get injured but i like the
idea that he's ready to play the whole
game i do i i'm with you i mean that's
why i think we love desean watson you
could see his love for the game his
competitive nature how cool and calm he
is in clutch situations whether it was
at clemson or houston yeah i mean he's
talented and you know to echo his
sentiment i was similar as a player and
i'm certainly not trying to say i'm
anything as good as deshawn watson but i
did like the preseason you know
especially when i was getting close to
being a starter or being the starter i
felt like you know it was a good way to
get some like
bullpen sessions like in baseball you
know without you know necessarily having
to face off against aaron judge and
everybody like that oh i get to get out
there run some of the basics of our
offense their defense is kind of basic
they don't have all their stars out
there and it can give you confidence
going in the regular season to go okay
i've been out here i've had a little
success already and i can build on that
and i'm really confident going to week
one because i've been throwing lasers in
the preseason and you can fool yourself
and be like you know who cares that it
was against the second team or whatever
i was good i felt good and i think i do
think there's something to that
um let's shift over to the arizona
cardinals we still don't know what that
offense is going to look like although
if you pay attention to college football
and texas tech the air raid offense the
the ultimate version of that loose
college drawed up in the dirt will it
work at the nfl level and lamarcus
joyner the raiders safety said after the
game when the raiders played the
cardinals week two of the preseason he
described the offense as a pretty boy
offense and or pretty boy football and
some cardinals players took exception to
it justin pugh joked about it he said
yeah we got some good looking guys what
do you want from us but uh
is the is it like a lesser brand of
offense should should
old school hardcore football people look
down their nose at this kind of an
offense that the cardinals plan to run
chris i think it's fair to question it
and whether it can be successful i mean
we haven't really seen that many college
teams really win and go to national
championships winning that way right i
mean we really haven't when you talk
about alabama okay clemson might be
about as close as we've seen to that but
clemson doesn't like abandon the run
game i think there's a lot of questions
about how this offense will translate to
the nfl certainly for me you know i know
they're gonna be able to get you know
some cheap yards in the past game and do
all those things but is there enough
inventory in that offense when it
becomes week three and week four and so
on where teams are starting to go oh
there's tendencies here and when they
get in this formation they like to do
this and when they're in that formation
they do that
that's where i really worry about it
added to the fact of
i still think you got to get underneath
the center a little bit mike in the nfl
and come downhill and run the football
that way and i think that's what
lamarcus joyner's looking at he's going
this is big 12 football this is seven on
seven that's why we talk about big 12
being crappy at defense and everything
else and there's no physical nature
about the offense and i hope that cliff
kingsbury can unleash some of that and
get some downhill run game with david
johnson because i think he thrives in
that environment i also think it'll help
kyler murray mike if you can run
downhill the boo legs the play actions
getting him separated from the line of
scrimmage to where he can see the field
better a lot like we've seen from
russell wilson i think that will be a
very good tool for that offense to have
it's a very subtle point because you
can't have a running game out of the
shotgun but the difference is if you've
got an eye formation and you get the
snap instantaneously and you turn the
the running back has a head of steam
when he gets the ball and hits the hole
and that can develop more quickly the
play develops so much more slowly when
you run out of shotgun because first you
got to get the snap and then you got to
turn and your back is standing still
when he gets the ball
already running and going horizontal to
a degree
yeah and and you know again if you've
got a great offensive line it won't
matter but there's something to be said
for hitting the hole quickly and busting
through it to the second level it's
harder to do when you're running the
ball out of shotgun and also it's just
the variety chris the thing that that
that i always say the more you can make
the defense guess that's right a run is
it a pass and the longer you can delay
that process so what that's why the rpo
works so well yeah you you force the
defense to continue guessing after the
snap and then you wait for them to
commit and you burn them the other way
and and that's that offense lacks it and
and uh you're right after four or five
weeks and they see what they do and they
break down the film and they come up
with ways to confuse kyle or murray and
and the and look
i i people people say oh kylie murray
was joking when he said to antonio brown
why they got to bring the house on me
bro i don't i think he was a little
irritated i think he's a little
frustrated and this is a guy who has not
encountered much adversity while playing
football it's always come easy to him i
want to see
how does kyler murray deal with a
three-game losing streak how does he
deal with a final stat line of five for
23 with two interceptions and 87 yards
if that happens how does how does he
react to that it's not going to be like
it was in college in high school and and
you know maybe that gives him the
determination to play even better to to
fit the ball through tighter windows to
to be a better quarterback to be more
dialed in he needs to be he needs to do
what deshaun watson did right sean
watson you know hey in college the
window's that big and sometimes he was
outside of it in the nfl the window's
this big and he threads the needle
that's right as needed and and will
caller murray step up to that he's got
the arm yeah the ball's got the pop but
it's so much more than that yes it is
and you made all the right points about
the i formation and and again i i you
know
i challenge people to listen to this
aspect too a lot of these defensive
players coming to the nfl are more
comfortable seeing this type of arizona
offense because that's what they're
seeing in college rather than seeing oh
sean mcvay
sean payton josh mcdaniels kyle shanahan
whoa i formation guards are pulling holy
cow what do i do think about if you're a
linebacker playing that type of offense
oh there's todd gurley i got to get to
him oh there's todd gurley i gotta get
to him oh there's todd gurley i gotta
get to him oh wait jared goff has the
ball oh man robert woods is behind me
now it's a 20 yard completion it's the
best way to create explosive plays and i
think that's why you've seen teams like
the patriots the rams the saints go that
route here as of late because one
they've recognized college football
players are not used to seeing the style
of football right now this is actually
different even though it's old school
that you got guys like you and me this
is actually different for the new school
guys and a lot of young defensive
coaches don't even know how to defend it
defensive players don't know how to
defend it and it's a great way to get
explosive pass plays in the passing game
that's really the best part about it
one last point before we move on a wise
man once told me that any time a player
says something that is controversial
about an opponent or has some nickname
like pretty boy football chances are
they didn't come up with it chances are
they heard it in a meeting room from
either their head coach or their
coordinator right or that that this is
something that the raiders were saying
about the cardinals just because
lamarcus joyner is the one who said it
yeah there's a disdain among the raiders
coaching staff chris and it possibly
goes
all the way up to chucky himself calling
it pretty boy football but uh you know
that may have been something that ended
up on the cutting room floor for hard
knocks right but there's a chance that
that's where it came from i think you're
i would i would bet if you made me
better if it came from that or lamarcus
joiner made it up himself i would
imagine that either in the secondary
room or the defensive full meeting room
that that came up during the week you're
right about that
all right something that came up during
the program in the airing of grievances
we didn't have much time to talk about
it though the stephen jones comments
from wednesday about agents and he
didn't single any agents out but the
cowboys co in talking generally about
agents said
i have a lot of respect for most agents
i really do i think they're trying to do
their job for these players but i do
think sometimes they don't have the end
game that maybe the players should and
we do i think sometimes our players have
to realize that representatives don't
always have what's in the best interest
getting the very most they can for the
players may not be in the interest of
their long-term future if they want to
and i'm totally con convinced all our
players do want to win championships and
keep these young players right now i
don't think the representatives and
they're all good ones feel like that's
their problem look i i understand that
agents are primarily focused on
maximizing the recovery for the player
because that maximizes the recovery for
themselves
but
do not tell me
that the team has the player's long-term
best interests at heart they do not by
definition they do not the team worries
about what the team what did jerry jones
say tuesday the team takes precedence
not the player the team so the player
doesn't care about the long-term best
interest of the player think about this
chris right now the cowboys have 90 guys
on the roster right 37 of them are going
to be said see you later we love you
thanks for everything you did now get
the hell out of here they're not laying
the foundation for these guys long-term
futures they want what's best for the
team what's best for the team is getting
these guys to take less and if you can
undermine their relationship with their
agents to get them to take less you're
acting in the best interest of the team
that's what this is all coming from guys
so don't fall for it they are trying to
help themselves they're not trying to
help you they help themselves by
convincing you that your agents aren't
helping you i don't think the jones
family became the jones family by the
approach of uh we won't try to get the
most we can get i don't think so i just
have a feeling oil tycoons what they do
with the cowboys it always seems like
they're trying to get the most they can
get out of everything so i don't like
that hypocritical stance let alone
there's no such thing as long-term
future in the nfl and it doesn't exist
at the running back position so you know
again you can cry me a river with all
that crap talk that's just not true i
just i can't stand you know i'm on the
player's side and i'm especially on
ezekiel elliott's side with this one and
oh yeah long-term future until what he
comes out there and sacrifices his body
again and then tears an acl and an mcl
and then there is no long-term future
the it's now the future is now and
that's what ezekiel is trying to do and
uh i'm i'm rooting for ezekiel elliott
as you know and i think you are too hey
i said yesterday if jerry jones was the
agent of any of the three guys on
offense they're trying to pay he would
be on top of a table screaming that
these guys are worth every penny and
these are the guys who are the ones who
put on the uniform cross the white line
and put their bodies at risk on every
given day and you know as well as anyone
you can't i mean hey yeah you can break
your leg you also could die on the field
as you almost did and that's not
anything to joke about and i'm not
joking about it the point is this the
players are the ones taking the risks
with their futures they're taking the
risks with their lives they're the ones
who have the skills and abilities and
the idea that they should do anything
other than try to get the most they can
for those skills and abilities is wrong
and i understand why the cowboys are
trying to do it because they've got this
great team now they're trying to hold
together so they can win championships
and build their own legacy and and
yeah it's got me pissed off and i love
and i love what the joneses do for
football but let's not get the roles
twisted right and whether it's a guy
who's representing himself whether it's
a guy who hires a lawyer to help him out
on an hourly rate whether it's an agent
who takes a percentage
you are in control of the player's
interest and the team never is and don't
let anyone ever tell you that the team
is acting in the best interest of the
players they are always and only acting
in the best interest of themselves and
that's the way it's supposed to be yep
uh a hundred percent and and you know
too i know
i'm not on the jones family side with
this conversation but you you did say
that they've done a lot of great things
from the sport and i do respect that but
you know again this is just uh i don't
know bargaining talk whatever it is
they're trying to lower the price
they're trying to cross the line
they've crossed the line twice this week
in my opinion yes yeah it crosses the
line by by questioning or by trying to
force
the players to question whether the
people hired to look out for their best
interests are really looking out for
their best interests and and look there
are some conflicting motivations that
come into play agents have said i don't
get three percent of the super bowl ring
i don't care if my guy wins a
championship but
the team is i mean this is a hansel and
gretel thing they are luring you into
the house with candy folks that's what
they're trying to do
you're right anyway yeah all right
i own number one
and again the joneses are great for
football and they've done fabulous
things in 30 years of ownership of the
cowboys and they have advanced the sport
but they are never acting in the best
interest of the players they're acting
in the best interest of themselves of
the league of their business of the
cowboys that's it we gotta act in the
best interest of pftot and end it for
now we'll be back tomorrow chris is
gonna have his top button unbuttoned
because aaron rodgers isn't playing
tonight if he does i gotta go i'm
telling you i know exactly where it is
denim jacket from the 80s i hope to god
it fits uh i got to go home
ty i gotta find a bolo tying sunglasses
but uh could be an interesting day
tomorrow we'll see how it goes see
everybody on friday see ya
[Music]
you